فبعد صدمه دامت عده ساعات تؤلفت حركه
الطيران في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لكن التساؤلات لا تزال قائمه حول السبب
فكيف بدات قصه راويه
المعنيه يا طاهر بعطل في نظام نور الخاصه
بمعلومات السلامه للرحلات الجويه ليتخذ
قرار سريع بوقف عمليات الاقلاع من
المطارات الامريكيه
بوقف ارسال رحلات جويه الى المطارات
الامريكيه الى حين اصلاح الخلل
تركزت المهمه الاعقد في مساعده الطائرات
التي كانت تحلق في الاجواء الامريكيه على
الهبوط بسلام وهو ما تم بطريقه غلب عليها
الجهد البشري
اعلنت اداره الطيران الفيدراليه عبر
حسابها في تويتر انها قررت استئناف الحركه
الجويه العاديه تدريجيا في جميع انحاء
البلاء
لكن ما الذي يعنيه هذا الخلل الفني
بالارقام بحسب مواقع متخصصه فقد تسبب
العطل تسبب هذا العطل يا طاهر في ارتباك
حركه الطيران ليصله الرقم الى تعرض اثنا
عشر الف الى التاجيل او الالغاء الولايات
المتحده ازمه واسعه النطاق كهذا منذ هجمات
الحادي عشر من سبتمبر عام 2001 حين اغلقت
المجال
الجويهفع شركات الطيران الى المدينه من
التشكيكي في موثوقيه البنيه التحتيه لاداء
لاداره الطيران الفرديه
وللشركات العامله في مجال خدمات طيران
الارقام الاوليه تتحدث عن ثلاثه مليار
دولار لكن الرقم قد يزيد يطهر الان الى
السبب الان السبب غير معروف حتى الان اذا
لكن اكثر من جهه تسعى وراءه البيت الابيض
اوضح انا بيضا طالب وزاره النقل بفتح
تحقيق شامل بشان العطل الذي تسبب في حاله
شلل غير مسمقه لقطاع الطيران
انه لا يوجد دليل على ان تعطل نظام اداره
طيران الاتحاديه كان بسبب هجوم الكتروني
اما المشرعون الامريكيون الذين قاموا
بادوار رئيسيه في الاشراف على اداره
الطيران الفيدراليه قالوا انهم سيحقق من
جانبهم في الخلل الذي اصابع نكمل
ماريا كانتوال وهي رئيسه لجنه التجاره
بمجلس الشيوخ ان التحقيق سيهدف لمنع تكرار
هذه الواقعه مشدده على ان الامريكيين
يحتاجون لنظام نقل جوي مرن
النائب البارز في لجنه النقل بمجلس النواب
وقال ان النواب سيواصلون المتابعه مع
وزاره النقل لضمان حل هذه المشكله جذريا
ناديه البلبيسي تابع التطورات الازمه منذ
الصباح وفتنا بالمزيد متابعه
اذا عوده حركه الملاحه الى طبيعتها في
المطارات الامريكيه هنا في مطار الدلس في
ولايه فرجينيا نرى الطائرات تهبط وتقلع
بسلام دون اي مشاكل طبعا هيئه الملاحه
قالت بنها سترفع الحظر وبالفعل رفعته نرى
بعض المسافرين هنا الذين ينتظرون حقائبهم
لكن رحلات الخارجيه لم تتاثر تحدث مع اكثر
من مسافر اتو من الخارج قالوا بانهم حتى
لم يعرفوا بالموضوع او بهذا الخلل لكن
التداعيات السياسيه ستكون كبيره وخصوصا في
مجلس النواب الذي سيطلب موسى من وزير
المواصلات طبعا الحديث الان هو عن عطل فني
في داخل الحاسوب الاساسي الذي يزود
الملاحين او الطيارين بالمعلومات الاساسيه
لذا كجراء احترازي تم همم حظر جميع
السيارات الطائرات في المطارات الامريكيه
من الاقناع همم لكن همم استبعاد له هج
سبراني الرئيس بعد ان قال بانه لا يعرف
السبب لكن هناك تحقيق شامل ومساءله وخصوصا
لاداره الرئيس بايرن حتى لو لم يكن الخطر
امني لا الامر غير مقبول بالنسبه
للجمهوريين وبالنسبه للامريكيين لماذا
يحدث هذا الخطا الذي يتسبب به ملايين من
الدولارات في الخسائر لكن العوده حتى الان
الطبيعيه على الاقل في مطار دالاس في ولد
برج الجدي